[Applause]
broke into the wrong house Gabrielle
Union kicks butt in her new thriller
breaking in but she's been fighting
crime since bad boys - well Special
Agent Sid Burnett is returning in a TV
spin-off Ellie's - yeah Congrats and
reprising that role but I want to know
is there any other iconic character that
you would like to see come back to life
oh I mean they are old they were all
living honey I mean Isis it still doin
cheers somewhere with Kirsten Dunst they
probably with a little lower back pain
I'm curious you know does she do Pilates
now we don't know I'm not sure don't
worry well we'd love to see the clovers
and Toros battle it out again on the big
screen but right now Union is gearing up
for the end of another iconic character
I'm Mary Jane Paul
BET's being Mary Jane is cancelled and
will air its two-hour series finale
movie this fall our fans gonna be
satisfied with the way things I think
fans will be very satisfied it'll be
airing in October we added more stressed
nut to the mix of Mary Jane's sex life
couldn't get love life couldn't get well
all of all of her life couldn't get any
more messy and complicated we had a more
stressed nut to the mix and I think
everyone's gonna be absolutely gagging
[Music]